North Korean leader Kim Jong-un has
arrived in Russia Russian media is
reporting his train has been spotted and
also risk just 100 kilometers from
Vladivostok he's expected to meet with
President Vladimir Putin in the coming
days well earlier in North Korea's
workers Daily website showed pictures of
Kim boarding his train Bound for Russia
American Diplomat said last week that
North Korea is ready to supply a
munition to Russia for use in Ukraine
Kim jong-un's Journey began from the
Russian Border Station of kasan it's
1200 kilometers by rail to Vladivostok
where Putin is attending an economic
Forum the entire trip takes around 20
hours we've got correspondence covering
both sides of the story shortly we'll
speak to Florence Louis who's standing
by with reaction from South Korea but
first we're going to go to Julia
chapovalova who is in Moscow for us and
Julia what do we know about the North
Korean leaders latest whereabouts
so basically according to Russian
sources Kim jong-un's train has a ride
in the city of usurisk in Russia's Far
East it's some 100 kilometers from
vladivastok at the moment there is no
information of where he's going to
travel anywhere else so no but we
presume that he will the North Korean
leader is expected to meet with
President Vladimir Putin as you said
while the Russian president is visiting
uh Russia's Far East himself
participating in the Eastern economic
Summit which has taken place in La Diva
stock right now and there are no details
by the way exactly where and when the
meeting will be held according to the
Kremlin spokesperson no um no press
conferences are going to follow the
talks between the Russian and North
Korean leaders uh Dimitri peskop has
confirmed though that there will be
one-on-one communication not just the
talks between the delegations and also
an official dinner on behalf of Vladimir
Putin in honor of Kim Jong-un has been
scheduled as well so the two presidents
are expected to discuss arms supplies
from North Korea to Russia for Russia's
armed conflict in Ukraine the move which
has been condemned by the U.S plus there
is a possibility of Russia's withdrawal
from the U.N sanctions imposed in North
Korea earlier that issue is also
expected to be discussed but generally
very little information about the event
itself due to uh to some secrecy reasons
what can we expect from President Putin
Julie what can we expect from President
Putin at the Eastern economic Forum I
understand he has just been speaking
well actually we're waiting uh for him
to answer to tell us a little bit more
about his potential meeting with the
president Kim but at the moment Vladimir
Putin just finished his speech at the
plenary session of the economic forum
and is now answering questions and uh
during his speech he addressed a lot of
domestic issues mostly he promised
high-speed motorways they would be built
through Siberia and the Far East to the
Pacific Ocean preaching also
basically told the government to prepare
a plan for the development and
modernization of aviation in the Far
East by March 2024 prior to the plenary
session that we Putin spoke with the
moderators of the summit sessions and uh
well he said that Russia is working on
weapons based on new physical principles
whatever it means as they will ensure
Security in the future of the country
and he also said that Russia is
interested in foreign Specialists
including and he spoke about
facilitating the procedure for them to
obtain the Russian citizenship and also
the Russian Federation will not slow
down the pace of development in the
forest in in the region okay thank you
so much for that that is Julia
chapovalova for us in Moscow
are we going to go now to Florence Louis
who is monitoring developments for us
from Seoul and Florence what more do we
know about the meeting between Putin and
Kim do we know exactly what they are
going to discuss
well a Kremlin spokesman has said that
the meeting is mostly going to be about
bilateral relations and we know that
these two countries have said they want
closer ties now but an analysis of
analysis of photographs published by
North Korean State media suggests that
defense topics are going to feature very
heavily in this meeting between Kim and
Putin now looking at the photos we know
that Kim Jong-un is accompanied by the
top military official that's re
pyeongchul he oversees defense matters
including North Korea's nuclear and
missile programs but it's also the lower
ranking officials that really give us a
clue that defense and possibly an arms
deal is going to feature very heavily in
this meeting now one of them is the
director of munition so that's the
department that produces conventional
artillery these are the weapons that
Russia will be looking for to support
its war in Ukraine now and then there's
also the naval Commander Russia has said
that the two sides are discussing the
possibility of holding joint military
drills and there's also the parties such
secretary he's in charge of North
Korea's space science and technology
committee so that's set up for launching
spy satellites so that really gives us a
clue that defense and possibly an arms
deal is going to be one of the main
topics of discussion and an arms deal is
really what U.S officials have warned
that North Korea and Russia will be
trying to
um to set up
and Florence of course we've heard an
arms deal would be a huge concern to
many in the International Community
absolutely because a U.N an arms deal by
North Korea would be in contravention of
U.N security Council resolutions North
Korea is banned from importing and
exporting weapons and also it's
restricted from certain scientific and
Tech cooperation now it would also help
Russia in its war on Ukraine but also
what's worrying countries in this region
and also in the wider world is what
North Korea could possibly be getting in
exchange for selling weapons to Russia
it could be getting technology that
could help it Advance its nuclear
weapons program it could be getting
satellite technology it's tried twice
and failed to launch a spy satellite
into orbit North Korea could also be
trying to get technology that would help
it build nuclear-powered submarines Kim
Jong-un has said he wants to advance the
country's Naval forces and that's why
we've heard Chinese that's why we've
heard South Korean president say
recently that he wants China he would
like China to play a stronger role as a
un permanent members as a permanent
member the U.N security Council in
curbing the nuclear threat from North
Korea and that's why we've also heard
from U.S officials renewing their
warnings to North Korea about selling
arms to Russia and also warning North
Korea that it wouldn't hesitate to
impose new sanctions okay thank you so
much that is Florence Louis for us who's
monitoring development in Seoul